if getting engaged and then getting
unengaged and going back to dating is
what works best for us
then i'm like let's do it
congratulations because
season eight of chrisley knows best is
here
you are going straight to hell if i do
it'll be with tom ford on
just because they broke up there's no
reason why nick and i can't be friends
oh my gosh what can you tease to fans
on what to expect this season yeah i
mean it's such a fun
season this season is definitely a
little
different in my opinion just because
we've truly dug into some
you know some deeper issues and we're
kind of letting our guard
down a little bit more and our whole
philosophy is kind of
if we can share something that we're
going through in order to help others
then that's what we're going to do
and you know for me i go through all my
relationships
ups and downs and i talk about
struggling with endometriosis
and you know being i turned 23 in august
but like
i had a doctor tell me all right you
need to be finished having kids by the
time you're 30.
so i'm like well if i'm gonna have four
kids i should probably start like
now and that's not happening so we kind
of talk about
my different options of like freezing
eggs and
it's just we go into some real life
issues and i enjoy that because
at the end of the day we go through them
but we find some way to laugh through
them cry through them you know it
doesn't always
have to be negative like i said i'm all
about your mindset
so are you mentioning the struggles that
you're facing in those conversations
with
with doctors i mean i feel like gosh
since season one i feel like fans have
really grown up with you and now
experiencing
this part of adulthood i mean can you
believe that it's been eight seasons
already
i know it's so crazy and that's the hard
part is people still
comment on my social media oh my gosh
did you ask your dad if you could wear
that
or did you ask your friend and i'm like
y'all i am not 15 years old anymore
i am an adult i am a woman
so it's hard for people to grasp that
like we are
young adults and trying to find our way
so i hope this season
truly does kind of force people into
that mindset
of seeing whoa like they've grown up
yeah
when will you guys know when it's time
to turn off the cameras
you know i think that's just a decision
that we will make as a family
when that time comes right now i mean
for me
i can you know i'll speak for me i just
feel like there's so much more that i
want
people to see and that throughout it all
like
i i learn through it you know um
and i want people to see my kids i want
people to see that journey i want
so it's just i'll go as long as
the opportunity's there um but who knows
that that could always change
season eight really kind of shows your
relationship with nick
and obviously calling off your
engagement postponing the wedding and
then kind of
moving forward after that will this part
of your life be hard to watch back on tv
now
you know i was just thinking about that
this morning
and i don't know if i'm gonna watch
tonight's episode
just because it is hard seeing
how we've kind of gone back you know
we're not going forward with a wedding
we're not
you know right now we're not so it's
hard to watch that on tv
um and the hard part too
is people only see like 30 minutes of
something
and they don't know the whole story so
they love to
come at you on social media be hateful
and kind of
give their opinions where they're not
really needed
uh so it's hard it is gonna be hard
watching it all back
and i'm not really sure how i'm gonna
feel
as of now i don't know if i'm gonna
watch it but we'll see
obviously you were supposed to get
married this past
may with nick and i noticed there was a
few sweet
instagram posts between you two recently
how are things going
you know we're just right now
it's just been such a challenging time
you know because of
covid i feel like right now it's like
the year for divorces and so you know
through cope and i'm like dear gosh
everyone's splitting up um
but right now you know i mean i'm going
to meet him after this
um but we you know we're trying to
figure it out and
what and i've said in multiple
interviews our relationships just kind
of been
unique to us and you know it's hard
whenever people are like okay you date
you get engaged you get married
uh and we just haven't followed that
timeline you know
if getting engaged and then getting
unengaged and going back to dating is
what works best for us
then i'm like let's do it so i feel and
that's a lot of thing too i feel like
men and women need to hear it's like you
don't have to follow anyone else's
timeline
you know it's based off of what you want
and i was listening to a podcast
yesterday and it was just kind of saying
like you don't owe
anyone an explanation for your life and
your decisions
you know you're allowed to have those
boundaries and you're allowed to figure
it out for yourselves
and you don't have to make someone else
comfortable while making yourself
uncomfortable so it's kind of the
situation that's kind of the place that
we're in it's like we're both doing
therapy individually
and just trying to figure out our place
and what we truly want out of life and
having those hard decisions
so we're not part of this whole divorce
culture
and of course your dad of all people
wants nothing but the best for you
but he has been so funny in these
episodes of this new season of like
it's like it's like his wedding and he's
like he was taking charge of everything
the wedding is off so is the engagement
what will god do to me for this fashion
to go to waste
is he still holding out hope for this
dream wedding
i mean he knows we're eventually going
to have a dream wedding now who knows
when it'll happen
but it's he and i've had my wedding
planned out
ever for like ever you know
so he was a little bummed and at first
he was like no
no no you guys can work it out and then
he took a step back and was like you
know what if this is what's best for you
then i stand by you and whatever
decision you want to make is what we're
gonna do
um but he was bummed because we had this
whole
you know three-day wedding weekend
planned
so wow what was okay what was the most
lavish thing that you had planned for me
i'm like i want my wedding to be a huge
party i want her to be a live
entertainment i want people to be
performing
i want you know i just want it to be a
blast
and you know i'll definitely have a
couple dresses
i'm still the dress that i had picked
out got measured for
everything that's still going to be the
one when the day is good
good i love that well in the meantime i
know you've been uh
busy also putting on that business woman
hat
and kind of diving into the world of
cosmetics your line
sassy cosmetics it's gonna be coming out
later this year right yes so
before christmas for sure um and
i'm so excited you know kobe kind of got
in the way it was supposed to be
launched a lot earlier but we want to
take every precaution necessary
and so i'm excited it's actually given
us some more time to kind of perfect
things
and makeup has always been my go-to and
it's just something to where it's like
if i'm feeling bad about myself i could
throw in some makeup
and feel a little bit better so it's
just i'm so excited for it it's gonna
you know i'm not just gonna release one
thing here one thing there
i'm kind of gonna go full force with a
full face palette
lips eyes everything so i'm so excited
and too it was a struggle to just kind
of get it
to where everything was at an affordable
price
because i never want someone to say oh
well i saw your line but
i couldn't afford it right and so i feel
like
everything that was important to me we
got accomplished i'm excited
how excited is chloe for you to have
your own line now because i will never
forget the episode where she comes out
of the bathroom and she just got
red lipstick all over oh she's so
excited and she was a huge inspiration
for a lot of things
because i wanted to make sure that the
colors that i had in my line looked good
on
every skin tone um and that you know
it was a challenge and because again i
didn't want anyone to feel like
it you know they wanted it but they
couldn't have it for
any reason and so it was funny because
whenever i got my lip shades back
i put them on me and then i put them on
her because she's like i want to try it
so i put it on her
and she goes this actually looks better
on me than it looks on you
and i was like okay i love it i love it
she's like she's gonna be your best uh
like tester of everything
because she'll she'll tell you how it is
i don't think she was like i don't like
that i was like
gosh it was a little harsh i love that
well speaking of her i
just want to take a moment to tell you
how much i
respect and admire what you have done
recently
during the black lives matter movement
because you are one of
the many celebrities who actually did
speak up and speak out and
use your platform to amplify
such an important movement and i know
you recently said that
you feel like it's your duty to you know
help bring awareness
especially because your niece is
biracial
i mean how how are you in the family
having these
important conversations with her right
now yeah i mean
you know we do take racism personally
um because we've seen it with chloe
firsthand
um and i'm not gonna sit here and say
that you know i
understand what people of color have
gone through because there's no way for
me to understand that
so right now i've just taken the time to
sit and listen
and learn and then speak up speak out
and you know create action and
right now you know i can speak on what's
in my heart and i was raised that like
you know i i didn't have that around me
i didn't have racism around me i
so right now i've just taken time just
to talk to some of my closest friends
who are of color and to just
hear their hardships and their
adversities that they've gone through so
that i can better
understand it and also help to
teach chloe and that's you know she's
had things said to her
at seven years old and it truly is
heartbreaking but i feel like now is the
time for all of us to
come together stand up and truly make a
difference
and i love that you mention actions
because actions do speak louder than
words and something that you said when
you talked about
the cosmetics line making sure that it
is
available to women and girls of all skin
tones and that's huge
especially you know moving forward and
how you can be a leader of change in the
position that you're in
well thank you so much